get euros about a sort of dystopic
future ruled by chefs an elitist near
future in a something that sure
resembles Los Angeles where warring
gangs of chefs water each other over
seemingly inconsequential points of
culinary minutiae
you know to serve tomatoes out of season
might be a death sentence enough our
hero is an old-school Edo style
traditional sushi chef who's very good
with a knife who really really doesn't
like it if you abuse his sushi this is
also a world where decapitating a rude
customer who would be considered
completely understandable and acceptable
so in a lot of ways it's an expression
of of both my worst fears and darkest
secret wishes early 60s I was a comics
nerd and enthusiast a wannabe comic
an illustrator of secretly after I saw
the first West Coast Underground's and a
few years ago I got to work on it on a
little project with Harvey Pekar and it
was deeply satisfying so yeah this is an
overgrown little policeman country I've
been friends with Joel for many many
years he's had previous experience of
editing comic books and graphic novels
history of violence being one of them
and it was just something we talked
about do it for a long time wouldn't it
be cool if we could work together and
wouldn't it be even cooler if we could
do a graphic novel you know on one hand
get your o Lampoon's and satirizes the
sort of worst of foodie excesses and the
most ludicrous aspects of of an industry
and an attitude that I very much benefit
from and I'm guilty of but on the other
hand you know as somebody who is a chef
for 30 years I will know that the inner
pain when you work hard bring to bear
years of training to try to make
something beautiful that you love and
people truly abuse or misunderstanding